when I hear the trumpet sound
I'm on a rides right out of the ground
ain't no grave can hold my
buddy down the dad
I see a band of a
ain't no great
pirate's life there ain't no grave hello
buddy Amazing Grace how sweet the sound
bassy
like real or just who in the hell do you
think you are
that was awesome
please don't shoot
okay what's that he says welcome to the
frickin guardians of the galaxy only he
didn't use fricken
look out oh I tried guys
[Music]
yeah
rough night night John wick Chapter two
wicked are in theatres Friday Dominic
Toretto
just went rogue you gonna turn your back
on family
I'm taking you down so write out where I
got
if you gotta catch da you're gonna need
a little help you want to tell me why
you just put me in a room with this
criminal you don't seem that tight
t-shirts cut off the circulation heal
brain you should get the disguise you
guys are gonna work together just don't
give up today
I got you rolling while you're watching
the game
they are watching the bay welcome to
Baywatch you people to lifeguards not
police you people oh you don't get to
say that you're just come on brother why
don't you guys the quick she's running
in somehow whoa whoa what are you
wearing
freedom that's desecration
[Music]
you want to know don't you why they keep
coming here to earth where are the
others
ones you're hiding I don't sell out
friends
your world is dying Optimus Prime
[Music]
the secret EPS
moneymaker IEQ
[Music]
it did not save your life
these dollies
you
a - mr. Monson you understand you're
trespassing right now right I have an
easement with the previous owner of your
property previous being the operative
word
what was this it's the guy till you
either get back in your nice truck
go play okie [__] somewhere else
hey Carl
it looks like mr. Munson hires some
muscle looks that way
he's a friend of mine friend with a big
mouth I hear that a lot and you probably
heard this too more than I'd like
and you know the grill Alma count three
and you're gonna start walking away
Yeah right to this one I have a lawyer
now - you know the drill this
Valentine's Day weekend everyone gets
some action how exciting yeah
I'm back John wick chapter 2 rated-r
starts Friday are you tired of not
feeling well
[Music]
take the cure and take back your life
side effects include sneezing dry eyes
drowsiness weight loss nausea skin
eruptions anxiety severe hallucinations
unconsciousness strong its
self-motivation murderous rage
in 12 days take the cure rated R
[Music]
are you recording this
nudee
[Music]
watch the new trailer now at Life movie
calm hey guys
it's a girl congratulations have any
idea who the father is
shut up what's xxx time alright let's go
three two one
this is dr. David Jordan our mission is
to intercept a research pond from Mars
16 steps to fix the shower I'm gonna
astronaut a gym teacher this is the
first capsule ever to come back from the
planet we have visual confirmation I
said this could be a major scientific
breakthrough well you can at the first
proof of life
beyond
lowering oxygen more carbon dioxide it's
beautiful
you're finally a daddy it's gonna be a
big custody battle over this one no
we're gonna keep it up here we're gonna
study where it's safe
you can't fastest growing every single
single it's a muscle cell I don't have
cell muscle
well brain how smart is this thing these
creatures wiped out Mars
millions of years ago if we let it get
to earth all human life let's kill the
thing good night moon good night moon
good night cow jumping over the moon
goodnight light in the red balloon what
is the primal instinct of any life-form
to survivor main stars
we've lost all communication good there
look at the atmosphere in 39 minutes
very intriguing but it could
mr. this everywhere
you
[Music]